[Applause]
i have some exciting news oh this is
very exciting
i'm really excited okay so i'm going to
be sitting at another news desk this
week
oh say what this monday and tuesday i'm
joining the cbs
this morning with gail king and anthony
mason
while tony decouple is gonna be out
because he's having a baby
giro this is huge i know
it's i keep telling my girls i'm just
like this is
such a dream of mine i love the news so
much and i just can't believe i found
myself at this
time and life i i can't believe it i
can't
wait to see you next to gail king i'm
going to be watching live drew
like texting you during the show i was
going to say i'll be asking your opinion
the whole way through roxy because you
are the best partner in news crime a
girl could ever ask for
thank you i'll just i'll be watching
i'll be outside the window waving hi
all right well let's kick off our news
today by looking back in a new segment
we're calling this day
in pop culture history
[Applause]
that's right
okay check this out on this day in 1977
a young radio hopeful took the airwaves
for the very first time
on wrnw in briarcliff manor
new york who was it just a little fella
named howard stern
howard was 23 years old and his first
shift was a midday slot with a take-home
pay
of 96 bucks a week he now reportedly
makes
1.9 million a week
but listen we all know where that went
he changed the world
he's the king of all media and he grew
his signature persona
and his full body take no prisoners
interviewing style
and he became the most fined
radio host in fcc history after a
44-year career he's still going strong
and i remember the first time that i was
interviewed by him i've interviewed
people for
20 years now and i thought to myself
after he interviewed me i thought i'm
such a better interviewer
because of what i just sat there and saw
him do
he's so well researched and yet he leads
it as a disarming conversation there is
no one better
in the business than howard stern and
who knew a shock jock
who made 96 bucks a week would become
the interview of a lifetime if you are
lucky enough
to be in his hot seat well you're very
lucky and i
hats off to howard stern the best of the
best howard all right
next don't never say never ever ever
ever
ever because sometimes x's do get back
together
the independent says rumors are swirling
have you seen this
jennifer lopez yeah and ben affleck are
rekindling the romance after
17 years remember they were benifer
oh it changed everything we now
put everybody's name in a mashup because
of benefir
well yeah they were the first and now
they're benefited 2.0
people are thinking therapists say
though is this a good idea to get back
with your ex
they say before you get back together
you should examine why you broke up in
the first place
and try this imagine that you never met
your ex before
and if you met them now as strangers
would you be totally attracted
because it's like are you just thinking
about how good it was at one point
the romance of that hmm have you ever
gotten back with an ex
oh my god around the bend
if i dated 17 years ago a guy
i am so not the same person my issues
back then
would not be my issues now and so i
think about myself in that context
and i have to give it up to people
because i've changed so much
interesting hmm you really changed my
mind drew interesting
well luckily we never have to break up
frosty we can just stay together
you